توابيت واحدة بجانب أخرى بجانب
أخرى بجانب أخرى مصطفة في
كنيسة في شمال إيطاليا ، مركز
تفشي فيروس كورونا في هذا البلد ،
يعني التباعد الاجتماعي أن العائلة
والأصدقاء لا يمكنهم قول وداعهم الأخير ،
كان المرضى بمفردهم وهم
يحتضرون بشكل افتراضي.  آلة شريرة شريرة
كانوا أناسًا كما يقول الأب ماريو كارت
مالاتي الذي مات دون أن يسمعهم أحد
أو يراهم دون إمكانية
التحدث إلى أحبائهم دون أي شخص
يريح معدلات ناكا
ولكن الآن كوفين 19 قتلت عددًا أكبر من الأشخاص
في إيطاليا أكثر من أي مكان آخر في  الأرض
، تم دفع نظام الصحة العامة ، وهو أحد أفضل أنظمة الصحة العامة في أوروبا ، إلى أقصى الحدود ،
حيث قتل المرض أكثر من 50 من
العاملين في المجال الطبي ، وأصيب أكثر من 7000 شخص
بالمرض ، وقد أصبحت إيطاليا قيد الإغلاق منذ
ما يقرب من ثلاثة أسابيع ، وقد تكون الإجراءات الشديدة
قد بدأت تؤتي ثمارها.  ماري
لا أثر ، يجب أن نرى عددًا أقل من الأشخاص
يصلون إلى قسم الطوارئ كما يقول
، وسنكون قادرين على رعاية المرضى بشكل أفضل
حتى لو بدأت الأرقام
في تسوية الضرر الذي لحق
بالفيروس التاجي لهذا البلد ، وهو أمر
مذهل مساء الجمعة 24-  بلغ
عدد القتلى في الساعة 969 مساء السبت ،
وأفادت السلطات بأن 889 شخصًا آخر
قد لقوا حتفهم إذا كان هناك ضوء في نهاية
هذا النفق ، فهو في أحسن الأحوال بصيص خافت ،
صباح الخير
لم أبدأ إلا اليوم وأغلق الحجر الصحي
الساعة الثامنة تقريبًا في
في الصباح الآن ، قرأت بعض الصحف
على الخط ، لدي بعض الأشياء الأخرى لأفعلها ،
هذه مساحة صغيرة حيث أقضي
الكثير من الوقت حوالي الساعة 11
صباحًا الآن هذا هو الشارع خلف
منزلنا وعادة ما يكون هناك أشخاص  في الخارج
، يمكنك رؤية أشخاص مغسلة
بالخارج ولكنك لا ترى أي شخص في
الخارج كثيرًا لدرجة أنهم يغلقون
كل شيء والآن أصبح الأمر
مختلفًا تمامًا لا يُسمح لنا بالانتقال
بين المدن ما لم يكن لديك
السبب المنطقي هو
[موسيقى]
هناك حديقة هنا بجوارنا
اعتادت أن تكون مليئة بالأطفال خاصة
عندما أغلقوا المدارس لأول مرة
ولكن Carabinieri جاءوا وأجبرتهم جميعًا على
العودة إلى المنزل حتى لا يتمكنوا من جمع ما يقرب من
2  مساءً.  في فترة ما بعد الظهر الآن ، هذا هو
المكان الذي أظل مشغولًا فيه في فترة ما
بعد الظهيرة في محاولة للبقاء بعيدًا عن المشاكل ،
إنه مصرفي غير معروف ، أعني أنه قد
لا يكون في أي مكان في يوم آخر بسبب
إغلاق الفيروس ليس كثيرًا لا يختلف كثيرًا ،
إنه هادئ جدًا يمكنك سماعه  المياه جارية ،
إنه منزل شخص آخر في الشارع
لم أر قط شيئًا كهذا من
قبل أن تكون مثل مدينة أشباح